arnaud bedetti bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors on vient
d'entendre l'avis de plusieurs français
sur ce fameux pass sanitaire le
gouvernement en tout cas compte sur ce
fameux pass dans sa stratégie de lutte
contre la propagation du virus
il aura fallu que le premier ministre
appelle ses troupes à 1 mardi soir pour
voter en faveur de ce passé ignorer le
premier vote beaucoup de députés en
colère comme nicolas dupont aignan y
regarder il est quand même incroyable
que le gouvernement parce que le
l'assemblée nationale n'a pas voté comme
il le souhaitait qu'il a été désavoué
rejeté annonce maintenant un amendement
et qu'on ne peut même pas le sous-amendé
alors déjà c'est choquant et tous les
français qui nous regardent vont
comprendre le mépris cas le ministre de
la santé qui d'ailleurs pendant toute la
soirée d'hier n'a fait que regarder son
portable on ne peut même pas contrat
vendée c'est à dire sous-amendé parce
que le système ne marche pas et c'est ça
votre démocratie en israël beaucoup de
français un n'ont pas compris qu'un
premier vote à l'assemblée nationale
puisse être balayés aussi rapidement
quel est votre regard ce type de
manoeuvre est ce que finalement il n'y
aura pas quelque chose a changé dans la
réalité c'est qu'il ya un contexte
politique où on voit bien que le
principal allié parlementaire de la
république en marche le modèle m'a voulu
faire ressentir très nettement sa
différence lors du premier vol a
finalement conduit au fait que la
proposition initiale de pas salutaire a
été rejeté par la majorité des députés
on peut penser aussi que le premier
ministre s'appuie sur finalement une
évolution malgré tout de l'opinion qui
sembleraient à ce stade si l'on regarde
un certain nombre de sondages favorables
à l'instauration de ce pass salutaire et
c'est certainement en s'appuyant sur dix
ont une opinion publique qu'ils
considèrent qu'on plus tôt aujourd'hui
en tout cas favorable à l'instauration
de ce pass sanitaire qui l'a incitée
vraisemblablement à dison
quasiment les heures qui suivent nous a
proposé un deuxième voie temps c'est
vrai que ça pose un problème ça pose un
double problème d'abord ça pose le
problème que finalement la démocratie
lorsqu'elle s'exprime de manière
défavorable dans ce pays qu'ils
s'agissent e par voie référendaire
souvenons nous en 2005 ou pas voire
représentatives comme ça a été le cas au
parlement n'est pas finalement respectée
que très rapidement les dirigeants
décident de notre passé l'expression
d'une vente pour imposer leurs décisions
ça c'est le premier le premier le
premier point le deuxième point que ça
pose c'est la question du passé ni terre
en effet on peut considérer aujourd'hui
qu'il existe un certain nombre d'acteurs
économiques qui considèrent qu'il va
falloir redémarre et que la condition du
redémarrage c'est d'établissements de ce
pass sanitaire c'est en tout cas une
position qui aujourd'hui est semble-t-il
eu défendu par un certain nombre de
professionnels dans un certain nombre de
secteurs notamment celui de la la
restauration mais ça n'en pose pas moins
sur le fond un problème qui est un
problème capital qui est celui des
libertés publiques
alors on entendait nicolas dupont aignan
s'agacer de voir les démunis sur leur
smartphone
regardez cette séquence avec le député
lr thierry breton tout d'abord monsieur
rémy nice voudrais vous inviter à
quitter vos smartphones ça suffit ces
méthodes un peu de respect si tout à
l'heure l'article 1er été rejetée c'est
à cause du mépris que vous avez avec le
parlement vous êtes ici devant la
représentation nationale
vous nous regarder dans les yeux et vous
arrêtez d'avoir les yeux fixés sur votre
écran
c'est compris non mais je vous le dis
très sincèrement parce que ça suffit
maintenant
donc la question qui se pose c'est de la
politesse c'est du respect c'est
simplement ça
on en a assez du mépris de ces milices
qui viennent qui va en deux heures le
répondent pas en question qui pianote
anticipant qui sur leur écran vous êtes
là pour répondre à nos questions nous
sommes là pour vous interroger
c'est notre devoir est donc ça suffit
maintenant la colère de xavier breton
monde ont calé elle est révélatrice pour
vous cette séquence
oui elle est intéressante parce que
montre qu' il y a toujours un soupçon de
metric qui plane au dessus de ce
gouvernement c'est à dire un
gouvernement qui finalement ne
l'entendrait pas et convainc
intermédiaires qui n'entendrait pas les
députés qui n'entendrait pas tout
simplement la société c'est une marque
de fabrique qui s'était installé dans la
perception que un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens y compris les députés on
l'envoie de l'opposition au de l'action
de la majorité
alors bon on est en plus il faut le
rappeler quand même dans un contexte qui
est un contexte électoral puisque dans
quelques semaines les françaises et les
français vont être convoqués pour élire
leurs conseillers régionaux et leurs
conseillers départementaux
on peut imaginer que ce contexte aussi à
jouer dans la prise de position du modem
lors du vote
le modem est un parti qui contrairement
à la république en marche dispose d'une
implantation locale d'une implantation
territoriale avec des élus locaux et car
vous livrez sympa moment là aussi
marquer sa différence par rapport à une
majorité en tous cas un parti
majoritaire la république en marche qui
est souvent considérée comme partie hors
sourde et finalement qu'est ce que
traduit cette séance cette séquence est
traduit en fait le coup de colère d'un
député de l'opposition qui considère que
les ministres qui sont aux bons du
gouvernement montre une forme de
négligence évidente vis-à-vis de la
représentation parlementaire comme
parfois le gouvernement augmente aurait
une forme de négligence par rapport à la
réalité des territoires où il ya
toujours sur le pass sanitaires et bien
certains ministres
on changer la vie en tout cas la
ministre de la culture elle est
aujourd'hui favorable à ce n'était pas
le cas en avril dernier regardez c'est
un outil qu'il s'agit d'abord de
préparer techniquement et ensuite de
voir son acceptabilité par la population
parce que cela pose des problèmes
éthiques
- ministre de la culture conditionner
l'entrée dans un lieu de culture un
passeport sanitaires j'avoue que j'ai
beaucoup de mal ce qui va beaucoup nous
aider c'est le pass annie terre là il ne
s'agit pas d'un pass vaccinale
il faut le voir comme une procédure qui
nous permet de raccourcir la
progressivité de l'ouverture complète
alors durant cette crise sanitaire c'est
pas la première fois que le gouvernement
ou de ses membres change de ligne
comment est ce qu'il faut le comprendre
ce qu'il ya une pression du premier
ministre du chef de l'état en tout cas
ça compte la question de la cohérence
des propos est également de l'action du
gouvernement vous voyez bien qu'à
travers ces deux déclarations il y a un
look est absolument essentiel c'est le
mot d'acceptabilité et enfin encore une
fois ce qui se passe c'est que les
gouvernements aujourd'hui pilote souvent
leurs actions en fonction des études
d'opinion et ils ont constaté
vraisemblablement qu'une partie leur
serre ton corps par fortement
majoritaires mais majoritaire de
l'opinion publique était prête à
accepter ce dispositif du pass
sanitaires et ceci marque vraisemblement
l'évolution du discours de l'exécutif
sur 7 sur cette question il n'en demeure
pas moins que ça pose un problème de
fond parce que quand bien même il y
aurait il une acceptabilité majoritaire
de ce pass sanitaires les questions
éthiques des questions en matière de
libertés fondamentales se posent à
partir de quel moment
finalement un citoyen a le droit
d'accéder à un certain nombre
d'activités sans devoir exciper impasse
sanitaire c'est une vraie question
une vraie question qui se pose pour nous
et puis également pour les générations
futures
la vérité c'est que on voit bien que
dans les circonstances exceptionnelles
très souvent des dispositifs d'urgence
des dispositifs d'état d'urgence se sont
mis en place
problème c'est qu'un dispositif d'état
d'urgence il doit rester en place le
temps finalement des circonstances
exceptionnelles et il ne doit pas
s'installer dans le droit commun et le
risque aujourd'hui auxquels nous sommes
confrontés c'est que l'accumulation de
ces dispositifs d'exception deviennent
la norme et ça en effet c'est un
problème d'ordre politique c'est un vrai
problème en matière de respect des
libertés publiques et donc c'est un
problème qui se pose bien évidemment
pour nous et puis bien évidemment pour
les générations futures
alors l'action du gouvernement également
pointé du doigt ces dernières heures
mais cette fois c'est après ce terrible
féminicide de mérignac 1 des
défaillances soulevée par une mission
d'inspection un manque de communication
entre les services selon un premier
rapport
laurence garnier sénatrice les
républicains s'en est pris au premier
ministre
écoutez monsieur le premier ministre
tous les meurtres de femmes ne peuvent
pas être évité celui là aurait dû l'être
si vous vous étiez donner les moyens
d'appliquer des lois que vous avez
vous-même voter ma question est donc
simple
n'avez vous pas honte d'une telle
inefficacité de votre politique
alors finalement comment comprendre
cette inefficacité que l'état ait tant
de mal à faire appliquer sur le terrain
des décisions prises lors du grenelle de
la violence faite aux femmes
on revient que sur ce sujet là il y
avait déjà d'autres exemples avec de
nombreux dysfonctionnements c'est à dire
qu'il ya d'un côté l'affichage qui est à
l'affichage de communication politique
qui a été notamment à l'époque largement
relayée par celle qui était en charge de
ce dossier qui est aujourd'hui au
ministère de l'intérieur madame schiappa
et la réalité du terrain où on voit en
effet une chaîne de contrôle qui semble
parfois être soumises à un certain
nombre de
dysfonctionnement c'est tout le problème
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on a un
exécutif qui sur les enjeux régalien en
règle générale a compris que l'opinion
publique souhaiter une très grande
fermeté
donc il adapte son discours là aussi à
la volonté de l'opinion publique en
communiquant fortement on voulant
restaurer le rôle de l'état ont pourri
qu'on y z'ont une intimité pour les
délinquants quels qu'ils soient et
quelle que soit la forme de violence et
la réalité du terrain qui ne correspond
pas à cet affichage en termes de
communication politique
alors c'est vraisemblablement faute de
moyens entre autres faute de maîtrise
aussi l'administration
tous ces éléments expliquent ce décalage
qui existe entre le discours de
l'exécutif et la réalité la réalité
politique la réalité administrative qui
apparaît au grand jour d'une grande
partie de l'opinion publique alors
arnaud bennet il nous reste quelques
secondes peut-être une dernière question
après brune poirson un 2ème ex ministre
quitte la politique c'est benjamin
griveaux il a présenté sa démission hier
il n'ira donc pas au bout de mandat de
député qu'est ce que ça vous évoque ses
rivaux et finalement le fossé qui existe
aujourd'hui entre un certain nombre de
responsables politiques qu'ils sont élus
lorsqu'ils sont élus ils sont élus pour
un mandat un mandat complet
il ya des gens qui les ont soutenus il
ya des gens qui vont voter pour eux et
qu'ils décident tout d'un coup on court
le demande a d'abord donné leur charge
et la responsabilité
tout ceci finalement nuit encore une
fois la confiance que nos citoyens
peuvent avoir en direction de la classe
politique et je ne suis pas sûr qu'en
laisser ce type de comportement
rétablisse le lien de confiance qui est
absolument indispensable en démocratie
entre la société et le politique merci
beaucoup arnaud benedetti d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france je le rappelle
vous êtes rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire